Bruce starts this hour in Seattle
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show Bruce
thanks for taking my call mr. Ramsey
sure what's up so I've been really
hitting this dead thing really hard for
the past couple of months here I've
started following you
big fan I've paid off about $17,000 a
debt in three months Wow
yeah so I'm looking at now I'm doing
scorched earth and getting pretty
radical with this I have a home that has
about a hundred thousand equity and I'm
looking at selling that moving across
the country back to my family with my
family to save even more money take that
equity attack the debt even more so and
then live cheaper for a while and so I
kind of wanted to know what you thought
about that idea it's a significant move
a significant lifestyle change nothing
is permanent but it would get me closer
to debt free faster by using this equity
that's your only reason for doing it the
other reason is being closer to family
I've got a third child on the way so
that would be nice
but it's basically in the middle of
nowhere so it's going to be a lifestyle
change that my wife and I are like not
super stoked about but the same time
getting rid of debt is a huge deal for
us
and Mitch do you know like I stay close
to 150,000 dollars in debt on what
student loans some credit cards and cars
what do you own your car's total cost of
we have two cars one twenty thousand and
one about eight thousand won't your
household income I work I'm the only one
that works so I work two jobs right now
and I'm making close to three hundred
thousand a year
no I would stay where you are mm-hmm did
you don't want to move you make really
want to but I but I also mount the three
hundred thousand dollars a year you're
gonna pay off 150 thousand in two years
I wouldn't go through all this
disruption sounds that you're not gonna
make three hundred or you're moving to
well I will I work remote that's the
plan is to live as cheap as I can and
what are you doing for a while
software development yeah
but you're in the middle of software
development heaven right there correct
and when you move to middle of nowhere
it's gonna it is gonna affect your
income even though you work remote yes
because you're the proximity that you're
into the business that you do does
matter even when you're remote so no I
think I work for our in the Midwest I
work remote for them for a couple years
now okay but but I mean bottom line is
that if you were debt-free you wouldn't
be talking about this that's correct I'm
just trying to get there as fast as I
can but you make a ton of money you do
very well congratulations you have a
fabulous income and you're on fire
you're a project driven task oriented
guy you're gonna get there you're gonna
be done with this in I mean two years
easy less than two years here you
already done seventeen thousand three
months I mean right you're you're gonna
be fine I'm just gonna sit there and
plow through this and you know if you
want if you want to get if you want to
get froggy sell the big car but I don't
even do that in this case because you
know here's what I'm looking at look at
the ratio of three hundred thousand to
two to 150 and so seventy-five thousand
a year for two years you're done out of
three hundred that's it that's a that's
mailing it in yeah okay but if you did
150 out of 300 you're done in one year
right not counting taxes you know sure
that's still not exactly roughing it no
it's not at all but he just one of those
things where I've gotten the bug and I'm
yeah on fire and what I'm just trying to
tell you the bug is you know you're
gonna turn undo all this disruption to
your family later an emotional
disruption and moving is expensive and
it's gonna it's gonna knock you further
off the track then it's gonna get you on
the track you've already got the secret
sauce the secret sauce is how fired up
you are and that your ratio of income to
debt your ratio of shovel to the hole
that your any of a very large shovel and
you have a you know a large debt and
your very large shovel is going to dig
you others hole very very quickly now
that you're on now
game on there's nothing stopping by dude
I mean you're what you're what you're
going to go live under a bridge to do
this which means you're gonna do it yeah
yeah I don't I don't think you guys
wanna leave the family at all yeah we
don't really want to but there's a
proximity to a family question okay you
want to live there that's different but
that was not the discussion we were
having not really yeah you make 300
grand
got some airline tickets and take the
babies over there and show grandpa yeah
it's a good point you know it's not it's
just not that expensive I mean you can
do it now you know if but if you guys
want to be there and want to raise your
kids and in the proximity of family and
that kind of stuff and you want to live
in thing but you told me straight up you
and your wife were dreading joining
dreading living in podunk that's what's
exactly what you said so don't go live
in podunk man I mean you know some
people that's where that's their dream
is to get to live there but it's your
nightmare don't do it you've got you've
got and definitely don't do it just to
get out of debt hey thanks for the call